Speaker 1: So Donald Trump's former attorney
general, William Barr, is now coming out and
saying all of those election lies, Trump was
telling they were lies, they were B.S.
He had these lawyers working for him.
But the lawyers were a quote clown show.
That's a quote from William Barr.
And everybody now is saying, here is a guy
willing to tell the truth about the guys who
wrote a book.
He wrote a book, and now he wants to sell
the book.
And like everybody else, he kept the most
interesting stories for the end.
Now, did he actually object enough to what
was going on with Donald Trump while he was
working for him to say no more?
Well, only at the absolute end.
Remember, William Barr didn't resign until
December 23rd or something like that of 2020,
and he seemed to be wanting to get the hell
out of there before whatever was going to
happen on January 6th happened.
But he went along with it all along.
He was willing to work for Trump and on and
on and on.
And we can't let these guys be rehabilitated.
But William Barr says it's really interesting.
Here is an interview that William Barr did
with NBC Nightly News host Lester Holt, where
he says it was all
Speaker 4: B.S. and I told him that all this
stuff was bull and about election fraud.
And, you know, it was wrong to be shoveling
it out the way his team was.
And he started asking me about different theories
and I had the answers.
I was able to tell them, This is wrong because
of this, you're trying to set him straight.
Yes.
And you know, he listened.
He he he was obviously getting very angry
about this.
I said, OK, well, look, I understand you're
upset with me and I'm perfectly happy to tender
my resignation.
And then, Oh, you slept at the desk and he
slapped the desk and he said, accepted.
Accept it and then boom, he slapped it again.
Accept it.
Go home.
Don't go back to your office.
Speaker 1: You're done.
So that is a firing, folks.
Now remember that at the time we were when
this when this happened, when it was announced,
William Barr is leaving.
We all understood this.
This is a firing at this point, in all likelihood,
and indeed it was.
And it is just another one of these examples
where some see this and say, what a what a
great guy.
What a hero.
William Barr willing to tell the truth.
He's willing to tell the truth.
What is it, 15 months later, because he's
trying to sell book would have been useful
to hear this stuff at the time.
And there is another segment of this interview
where he talks about the clown show of lawyers
that Donald Trump brought out, and it was
quite a clown show
Speaker 4: and about election fraud.
And you know, it was wrong to be shoveling
it out the way his team wants.
Speaker 5: And then he also told Trump what
he thought of his legal team.
Not a lot.
Speaker 4: I said the reason you are where
you are is because you wheeled out a clown
show of lawyers, a clown show.
Yeah, clown car or something like that.
I said, it's just a bunch of clowns.
Who were you referring to?
Rudy Giuliani's crackerjack legal team in
my
Speaker 5: march, says the president shot
back listing two
Speaker 1: guys.
Obviously, Barr is right and it's funny to
hear him talk about those clown lawyers in
these terms.
But he was complicit with so much of what
went on for so long.
He misstated what was in the Mueller report.
You know, he's not a good guy.
Speaker 5: Ways he said Barr had failed him.
That's when Barr says he offered up his resignation.
Speaker 4: I said, OK, well, look, I understand
you're upset with me and I'm perfectly happy
to tender my resignation.
And then, Oh, he's left to the desk and he
slapped the desk and he said, accepted accept
it, which we heard already.
Oh, he slapped it again.
Accept it.
Go home.
Don't go back to your office.
Go home, you're done.
Speaker 5: When we asked the former president
about this meeting, he disputed Barr's account
and told us he was the one who demanded Barr's
resignation.
Either way, Barr handed in a resignation.
Speaker 1: Either way, it was a firing
Speaker 5: letter or two weeks later and has
not spoken with Donald Trump since.
He does not want him to run for president
again.
Speaker 1: All right.
So listen, why is William Barr doing this
now?
It's because he wrote a book and he wants
to sell a book, and there's this sort of rehabilitation
tour, and maybe part of it is also distancing
from Trump for future opportunities or whatever.
But it's almost certainly just to sell a book.
That's that's the theme they hold on to the
juicy stuff, or they're indignant and principled
statements until they have a book to sell.
I think they mostly do tell the truth.
William Barr or whoever Stephanie Grisham
wrote one.
And now I don't even remember all the people
who have written books.
It's just at a particular time for a particular
benefit.
They start telling all of those stories now.
The other aspect of this is any opportunity
that Trump has to talk about Barr.
Trump will almost certainly throw Barr under
the bus, so it's like, why hold back at this
point anyway?
But remember, Barr is not a good guy.
It's like, Hey, Mitt, Romney said one thing
that makes sense, but he's still a guy I don't
really agree with politically.
All of that former Trump people that are worse
because they worked for Trump.
Barr lied to Congress with regard to important
parts of the Mueller report.
He he lied in that letter that he put out.
Remember the letter summarizing the Mueller
report, which wrongly said that it cleared
Trump of obstruction, which the Mueller report
very clearly did not?
So if you're actually interested in this book,
I'd wait a few weeks.
It almost certainly will show up in the 99
cent area within a few weeks or a couple of
months.
That's almost always the way it happens with
these political books.
I will not be buying the book and what in
terms of the movement that Barr is now part
of.
I would be willing to concede that Barr seems
to be exiting the worst of the worst Trumpian
fringe.
Sure.
He resigned.
Slash was fired.
He calls out B.S.
when he sees it.
OK, fine.
But he's taking a step back to the Pence McConnell
Republican Party, which is almost as bad.
It's people who are in denial about this being
Donald Trump's part party.
It's clueless people.
It's people who were willing to go with whatever
Trump wanted for as long as it was sort of
beneficial to them and gave them access to
centers of power or whatever the case may
be.
He's marginally less crazy, I guess, because
he's willing to say this.
So for all we know, they're bailing on Trump
because they plan to build consensus around
Republicans nominating some kind of centrist
in 2024 instead of someone like a Trump or
a DeSantis.
But these are not good people, and William
Barr deserves barely any praise.
William Barr has done one percent of of all
that William Barr has done since working for
Trump as attorney general.
One percent of what he said and done makes
sense and seems sort of like morally grounded.
And so he can get that one percent praise
from us.
Good thing he's saying this.
He's saying it now to sell books, and I wouldn't
trust this guy as far as I can throw him